des familles dans les jardins à noël
c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle le château
de villandry n'avait jamais vu autant de
visiteurs en hiver après la table il
fallait sort qui en a couru les enfants
c'est le labyrinthe ouais ça fait du
bien aux beaux jours les jardins
tiennent la vedette mais là le plus beau
est au chaud à l'intérieur la nature
s'invite au château alors vous allez
voir on a fait plein de décor très
naturel il ya une grande galerie
rappeler la forêt enchantée où il a
reproduit une petite forex et venise
maison et ses personnages et ses animaux
de la forêt des fleurs des amaryllis
surtout des branches de sapin des
bouquets de toutes les couleurs
jalonnent la visite déjà le château par
le mec super beau mais en plus il est
vraiment mis en valeur c'est très
agréable on a été surpris par toutes les
décorations c'est pas le premier château
qu'on fait mais effectivement les gens
ont vraiment mis en valeur noël dans
cette chambre la blancheur du sapin
illuminé tous les petits animaux de la
forêt sont nichés à des coûts est assez
sympa c'est coloré c'est à ces vielles
ça met un peu de gaieté pour nous si
l'on regarde vers l'extérieur la
perspective des jardins à la française
change à tous les étages
on est venu d'allemagne fait un petit
tour ici donc ouais on est bien et
surtout ça montre un peu comment ça
pourrait être en été et voici le sapin
crèche le petit jésus marie joseph les
rois mages il a pris place au beau
milieu du salon oriental c'est
magnifique c'est festif
vraiment très très joli c'est le clou du
spectacle la fin de avec ce plafond la
qui est vraiment en détail le plafond
hispano mauresque du 15e siècle un
puzzle de 3600 pièces de bois sculpté
rapporté de tolède par le grand père de
l'actuel propriétaire c'est de l'avis
effectivement dans le château et même
pour nous qui sommes là régulièrement
c'est une bonne chose aussi ça nous
change effectivement comme vous disiez
le château au quotidien on a le réseau
gigabit et d'un coup l'un il est
totalement habité bien sûr
par la machine réelle entre autres écrit
au goût de la visite il y a le donjon
ici pas de décorations de noël mais la
géométrie parfaite des jardins épuré de
ses fleurs par l'hiver voilà qu'il pleut
nous reviendrons au printemps
[Musique]